pour les avocats de muriel bolle le
marathon judiciaire continue mais avec
un nouveau camouflet
ce matin la cour d'appel de dijon a
tranché elle estime que même menés sans
avocat la garde à vue de 1984 n'est pas
contraire à la constitution
pour qu'un dossier soit bien jugé il
faut qu'il soit régulier et donc notre
démarche dans le cadre de la défense de
madame bol c'est d'avoir une procédure
qui soit régulière n'oublions pas qu'en
1984 muriel bolle neucin crimine pas de
quoi que ce soit simplement les
gendarmes lui font dire qu'elle était
dans le véhicule avec bernard laroche
c'est tout est ce que pour autant cela
peut justifier une incrimination
d'homicide d'avoir participé à
l'enlèvement d'un enfant qui tend à son
homicide
absolument pas témoin-clé dans la sphère
grigori muriel bolle reste donc mise en
examen pour enlèvement suivi de mort
confiné dans la nièvre depuis six mois
la vosgienne de 48 ans a interdiction de
prendre contact avec sa famille et
obligation de pointer deux fois par
semaine à la gendarmerie
mais depuis quelques jours son état de
santé se serait dégradé selon ses
avocats
j'ai reçu il ya quelques jours à un
certificat médical qui indique que temps
physiologiquement que psychologiquement
madame ball va de plus en plus mal elle
a actuellement un problème d'isolement
parce qu'il faut bien reconnaître que l
es complètement placé en exil qu'elle
est en train de passer à côté de sa vie
à côté de l'éducation de son plus jeune
fils la défense de muriel bolle qui a
d'ores et déjà décidé de se pourvoir en
cassation